[Music]  happy anniversary pumpkin  things have been bad between us and i'm  sorry  i don't know when surprise isn't gonna  fix everything  i love you with all of my heart till  death do us part  i'm impressed you've made it this far  there's one final surprise  happy anniversary pumpkin  we're not leaving until we open that  safe 200 grand  in rocks we split the diamonds let's go  two people knew the combination to that  state the guy who hired us  and the girl she could be miles away by  now  she's still in the house  i wanna used to get hurt he wants you to  scream  such a perfect couple  i'm gonna cut myself free of you if it's  the last thing i do  [Music]  you